le régime d'accès à la propriété leur a
pas été bonifié dans le dernier budget
du gouvernement trudeau il est
maintenant possible d'utiliser 35000
dollars de son réel et non plus que
25000 pour acheter une première
propriété comment optimiser cette mise
de fort lors de l'achat d'une première
propriété avec nous ce soir charles
entre vignes fiscaliste bonsoir ensemble
suffit lyon félicitations votre douzième
saison
oui effectivement on est parti pour une
12e saison et on veut faire des sujets
importants qui touchent les gens comme
ça comme le régime d'accès à la
propriété est ce que l'europe est encore
populaire aujourd'hui de moins en moins
si on regarde les statistiques depuis
2004 le rap ne cesse de baisser en
nombre d'utilisateurs et pau jusqu'au
québec aussi en ontario où colombie
britannique alberta c'est vraiment
généralisée dans tout le reste du canada
et d'ailleurs vous avez préparé un
graphique pour montrer que dans les
différentes provinces au canada
l'ontario le québec l'alberta en verre
ici la colombie-britannique là depuis le
début depuis tournant des années 2000
baisse généralisée exact d'utilisateurs
ce qui est fascinant c'est au début des
années 2000 il y avait moins de jeunes
propriétaires qu'en 2016
mais regardez commun qu'ils utilisaient
plus le rap par rapport à 2016 autres
menteurs 2005 il ya eu plus de jeunes
propriétaires mais en utilisant moins
leur a alors je me suis intéressé à
pourquoi pourquoi il ya une multitude de
facteurs le resserrement des règles
hypothécaires les jeunes ménages
habitent de plus en plus seul il habite
de plus en plus chez leurs parents donc
sa cause que les prix des maisons
augmentent
l'augmentation des revenus d'emploi
n'oppose suivi la hausse des maisons
mais ce qui est crucial à comprendre
c'est qu'en 2009 il ya eu l'arrivée du
celi et l'arrivée compte d'épargné libre
d'impôt par le gouvernement harper à ce
moment là exactement et ce qui s'est
passé à partir de ce moment à l'autre
lorsqu'on regarde les statistiques sur
les mises de fonds
les jeunes utilisent beaucoup plus
l'epargne ordinaire et le compte
d'épargné libre d'impôt que d'autres
sources pour utiliser sa mise de fonds
comme le real y compris le rap dans 87%
dès qu on va utiliser le celi
pour utiliser sa mise de forme et leur
hier dans seulement une mise de fond sur
trois y compris le rap à travers le
canada donc est ce qu on comprend alors
que le celi devient plus intéressante de
leurs actes c'est 6 1 et premier réflexe
que j'ai pensé je me suis dit est ce que
c'est vraiment l'optimisation fiscale
est ce que c'est vraiment ce qu'il faut
faire et pas tout à fait la force c'est
de combiner les deux le celi et le reer
avec le rap alors ça s'appelle le celi
réa et rap
alors ce qu'il faut comprendre c'est que
la zone la plus payant pour une cotation
reyers et lorsque le revenu familial se
situe entre 30000 et 60 mille dollars
parce qu'une cotation reér dans cette
zone vont générer d'une part une
économie d'impôts mais aussi venir
bonifier tous les crédits d'impôt il ya
location que les ménages dans cette zone
ont droit alors si je prends un couple
qui gagne le revenu médian au québec
avec deux enfants 80 mille dollars par
année c'est sur le revenu familial
médian à 2 si l'on accumulé par exemple
30 mille dollars en celi pour leur mise
de fonds ce qu'ils devraient faire
ce serait dans plusieurs situations
puisque chaque cas est unique c'est de
prendre leur celi de le cotisé henry r
et d'utiliser le rap en suède
ce faisant leur 80000 le revenu familial
va baisser à 50000 30 mai la cause
ouvrière en or or en temps plein dans la
zone payante durée attaque ça génère
beaucoup d'économies d'impôt de crédits
bonifiés d'allocations alors si c'est la
force du récit ne pas oublier cette
stratégie a des 90 jours et donc ça
vient optimiser le réseau d'accès à la
propriété
exactement et ici on n'a pas l'argent
s'est senti nos auditeurs écoutent mes
trente mille dollars à ses limites
à deux c'est beaucoup d'argent on peut
emprunter jusqu'à nos droits arrière
inutilisés est ce que vous considérez
que une augmentation à laquelle on vient
d'assister il ya quelques mois passés de
25000 à 35000 dollars
est ce que c'est une bonne amélioration
est ce qu'on devra en faire plus est ce
qu'on doit faire plus compte tenu de ces
chiffres que robinson c'est un début
mais si on regarde le graphique encore
une fois en 2009 le
gouvernement avait augmenté 2009 si oui
il avait augmenté le plafond rap de
20000 à 25000 dollars à l'époque
et qu'est ce que ça va donner comme
résultat on voit pas nécessairement une
hausse du nombre d'études et attendre
durable au contraire c'est la diminution
qui poursuit de plus belle alors
d'autant plus gelé pomy nécessairement
sur le graphique mais le montant moyen
retirer au québec en 2001 c'était 12000
dollars et en 2016 c'était 14 mille
dollars alors sur 15 ans si on tient
compte de l'inflation on peut pas
vraiment dire que l'as moulins moyenne
du montant retiré à augmenter alors peu
importe comment qu'on augmente le
plafond ça ne semble pas être
nécessairement efficaces ou du moins
viser auprès des jeunes bourrés ça
stimule pas nécessairement les jeunes à
utiliser davantage le rap exactement qui
d'autant plus que le facteur dominant
pour l'accès à la propriété chez les
jeunes c'est la présence d'enfants c'est
l'élément souvent déclencheur qui va
faire en sorte que les jeunes vont
passer du statut de locataire
un propriétaire si on a des enfants oui
la présence d'enfants et si l'envié leur
amenant type au compte de la présence
d'enfants
je vais vous entendre sur le nouvel
incitatif de la schl ça rentre en
vigueur dès lundi
oui c'est exactement une veine incitatif
des ch elle c'est un prêt avec
participation du gouvernement
mais lui non plus un nouvel incitatif la
nati pour compte de la présence des
enfants donc ça crée une iniquité envers
ceux qui en ont parce que les besoins en
logement sont plus élevé plus il ya
d'enfants donc un célibataire au des
besoins moins élevé qu'un couple avec
trois enfants il ya besoin de plus
d'expérience de chambre et c'est donc
une maison qui coûte plus cher mais
l'europe ne tient pas compte de soi et
le nouvel incitatif qui va sortir le 2
septembre l'ancien opus compte donc on
rondeau maire dans l'iniquité
merci beaucoup charlie hunter villeneuve
pour ses explications merci beaucoup de
champignons